[Música]
con este primer invitado del día vamos a
hablar de la tensión entre israel y la
yihad islámica palestina enfrentamientos
que desde el pasado jueves se dejaron 44
palestinos muertos entre ellos 15 niños
cuatro mujeres más de 300 personas
heridas este es el peor evento bélico
desde la guerra de los 11 días del año
2021 pero cuáles son los orígenes de
este conflicto histórico pues lo
hablamos con el doctor moisès garduño él
es profesor de la facultad de ciencias
políticas y sociales de la unam y
especialista en temas de oriente medio
profesor gracias por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de france 24 muy
buena mañana del lunes empecemos
entonces para poner un contexto no de
que es la tierra islámica como opera
además a que busca este grupo palestino
bueno es un grupo de resistencia en
grupo armado pero se asimila mucho con
hamás que es otro movimiento que opera
en casa también y que últimamente pues
han tenido un apoyo muy singular sobre
todo en zonas de cisjordania que son
zonas donde no tienen sus bases
militares pero sí tienen un gran apoyo
sobre todo entre la juventud y hadise
lame que es un grupo pequeño en
comparación con otros han gobernado en
cisjordania o en la misma casa como
hamás pero últimamente ha tenido una
capacidad disuasiva muy alta en términos
de misiles y en términos del éxito que
han tenido con respecto a por ejemplo la
autoridad nacional palestina a quienes
mucha parte de la población palestina ha
visto como colaboraciones de israel no
con colaboraciones de israel entonces es
un grupo incómodo para israel son como
es un grupo que ha tenido cada vez más
presencia en la zona de gasa sobre todo
en el norte que es donde han ocurrido
estos estos últimos ataques y esto ha
llevado también a israel pues a tener
ciertas precauciones estratégicas
tácticas como las que hemos visto en las
últimas las últimas horas
digamos entonces israel hace estos
ataques a la yihad islámica para tratar
de mitigar este grupo para tratar de
contenerlo digamos y que no se
fortalezca que no se siga expandiendo
por casa
hay varios elementos uno de ellos es que
hay elecciones en israel son quintas las
quintas elecciones ya en muy poco tiempo
que va a llevar a cabo israel y
evidentemente el primer ministro geir la
pivb en nada ha tenido ahorita el frente
del gobierno pues ha querido también
usar la cuestión palestina para
presentarse ante la base social como una
persona fuerte una persona que puede
terminar con este grupo otro elemento
también es ir marcando territorio con
respecto a la zona del gas que es la
parte del norte de gaza la parte que
puede colindar con el sur de líbano en
algún momento toda esa parte del
mediterráneo es una parte también para
ir midiendo cuál puede ser el índice de
respuesta a este tipo de grupos en caso
de que se desate una guerra en ese
territorio y una de las más importantes
para mí es causar un poco de fricción
entre yihad islámico y hamás que son
grupos o les digo que operan en gaza
pero que no precisamente pueden
compartir una agenda aunque ambos son
patrocinados en su gran mayoría por iran
ambos tienen una agenda distinta incluso
hay otros grupos también y me parece que
esto una estrategia por parte de israel
para evitar que hamas entrada al
conflicto y causar un poco de fricción
porque la gente en palestina estuviera
pensando porque hamás no habría entrado
al conflicto y esto debido a que
recordemos que hace uno un año tuvimos
un evento muy similar al que estamos
presenciando y analizando el día de hoy
pero con hamás lo cual jamás pues no
está totalmente listo para una nueva
digamos ráfagas de operaciones con lo
cual pues la estrategia militar israelí
tendría todo el objetivo de ir minando
cualquier tipo de alianza o al menos una
táctica en este tipo de coyuntura no
recordemos que lo que dice es el fuego
todavía no está nada dicho porque hay
ciertas líneas rojas que han puesto por
ejemplo las libres de hamás y de la
yihad islámico para entrar en una nueva
confrontación militar lo claro y
precisamente no dices eso quería yo
preguntarle qué tan frágil o fuerte es
este es el fuego y si se pudiera digamos
o violar o romper este acuerdo en
cualquier momento de vida a la
fragilidad que todo apunta a esta tregua
además le quiero preguntar pues el papel
de irán no porque irán respalda a estos
grupos que buscan irán con esto
en principio a toda tregua que se ha
dado en este conflicto desde 1967 pues
ha sido frágil y en realidad nunca hemos
tenido algo parecido a lo que nosotros
denominamos como paz o algún tipo de
negociación seria no incluso ni siquiera
los acuerdos de oslo por lo tanto ahora
la coyuntura nos está presentando un
momento donde líderes del yihad islámico
pues han sido algunos asesinados y otros
han sido tomados prisioneros una de las
demandas por ejemplo del movimiento
islamista en palestina es la liberación
de estos líderes israel tiene
prisioneros mediante una digamos especie
de mediación o de facilitación política
que es la que siempre ofrece egipto esto
a reserva de que ya no haya más ataques
militares esto está por verse porque es
una línea roja que israel pues digamos
la naturaleza del ataque fue ésta
debilitar a la yihad islámica aprender a
estos líderes y si ahora llega a la
islámica está pidiendo la liberación de
los mismos pues no sabemos exactamente
qué tipo de negociación puede llegar y
por eso se puede romper la tregua por
parte de irán lo que me pregunta pues es
algo muy interesante porque irán y
político al igual que arabia saudita al
igual que israel o lo como lo es turquía
o qatar que están también buscando una
estrategia defensiva con respecto a sus
competidores en este caso israel y es
uno de los pocos estados que ayuda
económicamente a la reconstrucción por
ejemplo de casa cuando son atacados en
estos momentos a envío por ejemplo de
material de curación y por supuesto un
apoyo logístico y militar para ciertos
grupos como ya ve islámico hamas en los
que se espera por lo menos mantener una
especie de resistencia armada que pueda
mantener a flote los embates de israel
no hay formación dividida insisto que
hay mucho apoyo para estos grupos dentro
de palestina pero también hay gente que
no está de acuerdo con este tipo de
ataques pero bueno que decirlo si
también lo mismo pasa con israel y con
la violación sistemática de derechos
humanos que cometen las fuerzas armadas
reales tipo de casos claro moises muy
rápidamente 30 segundos como empeora
esto digamos la precaria situación de
salud de los centros de salud también es
suministros médicos alimentarios la
situación de gas
bueno esto es muy difícil se ha sorteado
gracias a organismos humanitarios como
la medialuna roja y la cruz roja algunas
instancias humanitarias provenientes del
mundo islámico ayudas de qatar
principalmente también en este sentido y
bueno al principio hay que decirlo no
este tipo de cosas están totalmente
obstaculizadas debido al bloqueo
económico que mantiene israel desde hace
15 años que esto ha mermado
prácticamente la vida de las personas en
casa estando expresas particularmente
del paso de rafáh que está en la
frontera entre gaza y egipto según de
los egipcios también han tenido un papel
importante vamos a dejar pasar este tipo
de cosas ambulancia el material médico o
lo que tuvo que ver con las vacunas por
ejemplo también ha sido importante a
través de este paso no es difícil sobre
todo cuando hay cortes de luz cuando hay
inflación en el mundo y sobre todo
cuando hay embates militares como estos
pues es difícil la situación en la que
se encuentra no los combatientes tanto
sino la población en gaza que suma
básicamente dos millones de personas de
los cuales 800.000 son niños